foreign
[Music]
thanks for coming today on the last day
next to talk about uh perfecting voice
applications we're going to be talking
about our new speech models talking
about how to apply it but before we get
started I'll tell you I'm Calvin Barnes
I'm responsible for the product and
Engineering teams part of the speech and
voice features here in Google Cloud have
with me a couple colleagues my name is
Harris I'm the product manager for
Spitzer text too uh I'm Jeff Curry's and
I'm A customer from Bill Canada
so we're going to be talking about a few
different things today I'm going to
start off telling you about the speech
apis everything has changed in the last
year since last next
we'll talk about our brand new
Foundation model for a speech chirp uh
that maybe you heard about in the
keynote or as part of the other vertex
AI talks Jeff is going to talk to you
about how they're using speech
technology uh to change a business after
Canada and then Harris is going to give
you a preview of some of the things that
are coming next to the speech apis
focusing on speech fine tuning and
improving the models even further using
our foundation models foreign
but let's get started talking about the
cloud speech apis most of you if you
attended the keynote or other sessions
so far probably have heard about vertex
AI uh and our speech models and speech
services uh are in the model garden and
we expose actually over 750 different
speech models including speech to text
text-to-speech uh first party
proprietary models from Google in the
model Garden
but we make those available
through the speech to text API but
before we get into that I think it's
important to think about uh everything
that Google has done in the speech space
over the last 20 years so Google's been
working on speech to text
uh for over 20 years now
and there have been a number of
advancements in that time so probably
some of you are familiar with the very
early products like voice search uh
dictation and gboard
and some of the more recent ones Google
assistant or recorder and dialer
features on the pixel phones
in uh 2016 we launched the
speech to text API which was the first
version of making this available to
customers uh to Enterprise customers
since then we've continued to innovate
and invest in research for speech at
Google to push forward uh what's
possible and bring speech technology to
more and more both customers and users
uh last year we talked about our
state-of-the-art conformer models which
are still available today the fastest
and highest quality
streaming speech models available and
today we're going to talk about our new
research the universal speech models and
the chirp Foundation model
all of this has come together
across Google to create this set of
services so even if you've never heard
of the speech to text API or use the
speech to text API from Google Cloud
or experimented with vertex AI you
probably have experienced speech from
Google whether that's using Google
assistant or Google Voice search whether
it's dictating with gboard on your
Android phone reading subtitles on
YouTube live captions on me the list
goes on but what we've done in Google
cloud is take all of this research in
all of these areas that we've used to
perfect voice and speech for a number of
different 1p applications and we make
that available to Enterprises and
developers in our Cloud speech API
the cloud speech API within the vertex
pre-trained apis
gives customers super high quality out
of the box models I talked before we
support over 135 languages and we have
multiple variants for multiple different
use cases like telephony dictation long
audio in those languages so you get over
400 out of the box models that give you
super high quality to get started today
uh but you can also use the API to take
this further customizing your output
with punctuation diarization uh as well
as fine-tuning towards specific words
and use cases and today we're excited to
announce new features on fine tuning
that Harris will talk to you about later
first though we want to talk about our
recent GA of the V2 of the speech API
which happened this past July
the V2 API is the next generation of
speech to text serving at Google like I
said in the previous slide we've been
making speech models available to
Enterprises for almost seven years now
and it was time to modernize some of
that infrastructure and that's what
we've done with sdtv2 so the same great
models that we were exposing before the
same endpoints and features that you're
used to but now it is available for data
and use residency in any gcp region and
also in the US setting us up for fedramp
high and il-4 for those of you running
protected workloads and other individual
requirements for data residency across
the world
it also exposes new tools for service
controls encryption and fine-grained
permissions on individual models and
recognizers so that regardless of your
application for speech to text you can
be sure that we can meet your Enterprise
requirements
uh finally we added a new endpoint that
I'll talk more about in a second called
Dynamic batch which allows customers
that have uh workloads where they maybe
have large amounts of speech that they
want to transcribe but they are not time
or latency sensitive to transcribe them
over a 24-hour period instead of getting
results right away this allows us to
take advantage of uh gaps that we have
in our infrastructure usage and provide
transcription at much much lower costs
our hope is that this enables even more
use cases to be able to take advantage
of
automatic speech recognition technology
by bringing it in at a much lower price
point
um V2 as you'll hear about is also our
starting point for new models and new
features like our trip Foundation model
and custom model fine-tuning
uh in addition to these new features
we've also listened to customers and
heard that one of the biggest blockers
for adoption was the pricing of speech
to text Services everybody's use case is
different and the amount of value that
you get from transcription can really
vary depending on what you're doing so
we wanted to work with customers to make
it possible to adopt uh regardless of
what their use case was so we've dropped
the base price on speech to text 33 from
2.4 cents per minute to 1.6 cents per
minute
and we've also introduced native tiering
so as your workload grows your costs
will grow non-linearly all the way up to
83 out of the box discounts for very
large workloads in addition I mentioned
Dynamic backs before so starting you
know with whatever size of workload you
have you can transcribe uh for much much
cheaper if you're willing to accept the
additional latency in getting the
transcript back
okay so now that we've talked about that
I think we should talk about our new
Foundation model which we also made
generally available in July called chirp
uh so this is in addition to all of the
speech text models that we supported
before and Chirp is based on Google's
Universal speech model technology so
we have an initiative at Google called
the Thousand language initiatives where
we want to try to support uh the vast
majority of the spoken languages in the
world and support very well uh every
language with more than one million
speakers
but we knew that this was going to be a
hard problem with the current technology
that we had for speech to text and
speech to Tech modeling because speech
modeling is a very data intensive
operation requires a lot of labeled data
and it just you need a lot of data for
each language
so what we've done with the universal
speech model is created a universal
model with one unified encoder that was
trained on over 12 million hours of
unsupervised audio so this is audio that
we have not had to label or get human
transcripts of in order to use it for
training in a wide variety of languages
and this allows us to not only support
more languages that where we only have
very small amounts of data it also has
lifted quality in a number of languages
as well so once we train that unified
encoder we then train decoders for each
individual language that we support and
today we're only exposing 135 different
languages through the chirp model but as
we label more data in more languages and
train more decoders we'll be able to
very rapidly add more languages compared
to how long it would have taken us to
add a single language before
so to show you some of the effects of
this you can look at the performance of
chirp on a variety of languages and so
you can see that
uh we get improvements across the board
here so on common uh English academic
test sets Libra speech we achieved over
98 accuracy on English with the chirp
model
uh but for lower resource languages
languages like Romanian polish uh where
we have a lot less data we achieved over
300 increase in those 300 accuracy
increase on those languages versus what
our current internal state of the art
was
um
and across the board on our YouTube data
sets we have an improvement across every
language that we have data for uh when
you combine it all together
you also get gains in what we call head
languages like English French Italian
German and Spanish especially on very
very challenging data sets so 98
accuracy will not be possible for every
use case like it is on Libra speech of
course but we also are achieving 88
accuracy on Coral which is considered
one of the hardest English language
academic data sets and
uh much much better than any internal
fine-tuning on just that test set that
we had done before
so we're excited to bring chirp uh to a
variety of customers in a
variety of languages and we will keep
adding more and building on the
foundation model of chirp over 10. but
it is generally available in these
languages now in the speech to text V2
API
all right so now to talk about how you
can use uh these models uh chirp and V2
and our existing models in everyday
applications to make it uh better for
your users I'm going to hand it over to
Jeff from Bell Canada to tell us about
what they're doing thank you sir
um let me go I'll walk you guys through
how we're using it today just to to
start with for those of you that aren't
very aware of what bell is basically for
the the non-canadians Bell is pretty
much Canada's largest telecommunications
at work we sort of split it into three
divisions one being Wireless so roughly
10 million Wireless subscribers uh wire
line so your home phone TV
and internet services about 9 million
subscribers and then there's a media
side to the business whether that's
running mixture of ads TV radio and so
on but that's sort of the overview of
what we are
for myself I think it was about three
years ago they brought me in to lead
this newly formed speech analytics group
so think about it is taking all of our
call center information uh our call
center calls turning them into text and
trying to drive value out of those
slightly different approach from what
most people do so most people the first
thing they want to do is go in there and
just build va's and chat Bots and so on
we sort of took a slightly different
approach where we were going to build AI
products that helped Drive the business
and improve the customer
experience across the business so we
sort of brought together a bunch of NLP
data scientists some analysts to sort of
help prove out the business cases and
then product managers to actually run
each of these Solutions of its own
product
um
so from there where we sort of led to to
how this Evolution would work if you
think about a general call center and
how it kind of works you have two
probably sort of normal ways in which
you would call listen in the past so one
being if you're old enough to know is a
sort of a y Jack solution or what you
would probably do as like eavesdropping
on the customer agent interaction today
so you would do that in real time and
potentially provide real-time feedback
to that agent the other is basically
going into a tool like variant where
you're kind of listening to those calls
after they happen maybe days or months
or weeks after but for the most part all
you're really doing is probably
listening to maybe less than one percent
of all those calls so when you think
about that for somebody who's really
sort of
receiving about 10 million calls a year
plus even on those 10 million calls it's
about 500 000 minutes of call listening
um and then you kind of do that
backwards math to kind of figure out how
many resources that would take that's a
that's a lot of resources that are just
dedicated to call listening
um and the other thing that comes with
that is that bias you know like is every
listener the same did I forget them to
look for it to certain topics so did I
ask them to look for empathy and if I
didn't ask them to look for empathy
they'd have to go back and redo all that
call listening so the way that we've
kind of approached this now is we we
internally term it a virtual coaching
assistant but that virtual coaching
assistant listens to 100 of all calls
and then we're able to go back and
rescore all those calls for different
attributes that we may want to to want
to go back in and sort of analyze
um
and how we did this sort of at a high
level here's kind of the high level
architecture of how this kind of came
about for the most part you can imagine
for us anyways there's an on-prem to let
stack it telephony systems that sit
there from those we kind of stream the
Mana this is a very high level
explanation but we stream them into that
speech to text pipeline we then used a
series of other connectors behind that
whether data flow pubs up topics and a
variety of other things write them into
structured databases and then run them
through the entire sort of vertex AI
stack
um
when we originally built this at the
time sort of vertex AI was a work in
progress at the same time so we were
sort of building all these things as
Google was sort of mastering them as
well too so it was a great experience to
kind of get them all in place the other
thing too is now we've relied on these
outputs so much that they're pretty much
ingrained in a lot of our day-to-day
operation systems
um
some of the key areas that you'll see
here the top three are probably the the
main three that we kind of focus on but
sort of that sales enablement area a
making it right program so you know
trying to trying to sort of intervene in
conversations and interactions that just
felt like they went sideways that we
just want to immediately try to correct
and then just general Improvement of the
customer experience so with all this
coaching and all these tools how do we
just generally make that experience
better and we sort of found enormous
gains through these speech to text
applications
here's a list of probably six that are
sitting in production today
um some of my favorites here probably
are what we call age and language
quality so if you think of this what
this is at its core is basically
evaluating the conversation that the
agent's having with the customer and
trying to evaluate was that agent clear
enough and how they're speaking to the
customer do they stutter are they
speaking too fast are they speaking too
slow are they
sort of just is the customer constantly
looking for clarity from that agent and
to be honest there's probably no way to
do that at scale in a in a sort of Old
World perspective so now we're able to
do that at scale and again on 100 of
those calls and sort of evaluate those
agents and performance manage those
agents based on Clarity
um another amazing one too which was
pricing representation so you could
think of it as a day-to-day Telco
customer you're kind of calling in I'm
doing an adjustment on my bill maybe I'm
adding a new service for moving a new
service what we're doing here is
ensuring that that agent is actually
sort of clearly explaining to the
customer what those changes and impact
on the bill is going to be and if they
didn't do that we can then sort of sort
of fix that with a few different ways of
of attacking the problem some of it
could be again going back to the agent
coaching to make sure they're always
explaining those issues it could be
further documentation or further
explanations that we actually send out
to those customers so there's a few
different ways that we could tackle it
but this was a huge use case for us and
then the last one that I'll sort of
touch on a bit is sales pitch quality
um I'll go into that right now and and
this is probably our Premier speech
product that we've put together
um there's a I'll walk you through the
flow of how it works so basically if
you're a customer calling in I want to
buy internet
one of our sales inbound reps sort of
picks up the phone
um talks to the customer and then sort
of closes on that sale so we started
transacted we finished the sale of that
internet product the key thing that we
sort of push for is any company would
push for is cross-selling and upselling
on top of that product so I've sold my
internet service now I'd love to go in
and actually sell them some Wireless
services so hey let's go in make sure
the agents are pitching correctly and
make sure that they're pitching those
Wireless services so
one way that we looked at this was you
know are they even making that pitch so
more times than not the agent's making a
pitch to the customer and we're they're
trying to close that sale but then the
added value on top of that ended up
being pitch Effectiveness for us pitch
Effectiveness kind of boils down to
three areas those three areas are
exclusivity so language around like hey
this is a one-time deal this is a deal
you know specific for you as an
individual and then also mentioning
highlights around high speed or network
quality basically how good our network
is and how good it'll sort of run your
different services and then explaining
the planned features and in full form so
for us those are the three key elements
that we saw as sort of a premium pitch
and had a kind of better sell as a as an
agent on the other side
um within the first 30 days of launching
this sort of pitch Effectiveness model
we sort of saw a 24 increase in
adherence which is massive I think part
of that ends up being like here's a
recipe for you to sell more and for you
to make more money as an agent so like
if you put yourself in their shoes how
do I make more money and these are the
things that we need you to do to make
more money and once they see that it's
actually working it's something they'll
easily follow the next piece is that
sort of then translate you're not going
to close on all of those but what it did
translate to is a 15 increase in
cross-sell
um which is massive so if you think of
every opportunity you're getting in
you're kind of closing now 15 more of
the time
so like for any business out there
regardless of the cost of your products
if you can sort of lift by 15 within 30
days it's a massive win so this is one
of our our biggest products from a
speech AI perspective that kind of
allowed us to continue doing a lot of
the work you do so if you think of if
you're in my shoes on the other side and
how do I sort of continue to get my
company to invest in me to do stuff you
got to Anchor yourself on value-add
products so this is probably our biggest
value-add product that let us explore
into all the different initiatives
um
so next steps for us so one of the
things we have at Bell is we sort of
have this B2B offering where we work
with large Enterprise customers these
large entry price customers who provide
all different services to so one of the
things that we've learned through this
whole process is how to effectively
manage one in ml platform in Cloud to
this end-to-end speech to text pipeline
in Cloud so what we're going to do now
is try to we've brought this to Market
and we're going to start offering it to
some of our Enterprise customers as a
service
the next piece is then applying all the
data we have against vertex gen AI use
cases
um
if you think about that again too the
key thing to these gen AI use cases is
you need data to to sort of provide
value out of the great thing that the
speech to tech services have done it's
created sort of massive amounts of of
data so we basically have tens of
millions of calls transcribed sitting in
structured BQ databases that we can now
leverage and throw against different
Genie gen AI use cases so and for those
that are really close to it all it is is
essentially a API call through a managed
notebook or even through a direct SQL
statement so it's it's allowed kind of
our developer team to go crazy here
um and then finally the which Harris
will walk through next is kind of
collaborating with Google on some of
these speech fine-tuning initiatives
there's obviously little pieces of
language throughout your conversations
that get transcribed incorrectly and
what we've seen is the better the
transcription the better the model
performance so even though the
transcriptions come through at a very
high level right now the better that we
can make them the better the models
perform and then the greater the output
at the end of the day so for us we're
very motivated to work with these guys
to kind of help improve that
um so with that I'll kind of I'll leave
it off to Harris to kind of explain to
you a little bit about what they're
doing on the speech fine tuning side
thank you Jeff
so speedfight tuning as Calum mentioned
um
we do a couple of different things on
speech to text we try to offer the best
out-of-the-box quality for the majority
of the use case that we have for our
customers
however we are seeing that whenever we
see the use cases accuracy is not a
single metric that is the same for
everyone so we try to come closer to to
as close to our customers as we can
so how do we do that we do it with
pre-trained models Straight Out of the
Box you call it through the API either
version one or version 2.
when you do it through chair
multilingual model very big one
non-streaming but you get what the
out-of-the-box quality and the
robustness of a very very large speech
model
we do it through biasing when for
example you have couple of product
specific names to your company that you
want this speech model to recognize
correctly
but the final step is to try to to
um to condition the models around both
the acoustic conditions that it listens
in your use case and also the Lexicon
let's see how we do that
so here's an example of a real example
actually from a call center at Bell so
you can see that this is a conversation
between an agent and a customer hey I
live in Montreal and I would like to
purchase a belt 5 internet
now pay attention uh here because you
can see that Montreal unfortunately
because of the acoustic conditions
because this thing is is getting
streamed through telephony you can see
that because of the sampling rate was
lower you can see how it was
misanscribed here and at the same time
you have a product specific name to Bell
which is called five
because the statistical representation
in our training models
five has a much better represented
representation there you can see how it
was misanscribed
if you multiply this thing by the load
that Bell for example has which is half
a million minutes per day you can see
that only two words out of eight
basically you throw out your um your um
your uh your application your Downstream
applications whether that be analytics
agent I think agencies or anything else
so how we do it how do we do that again
as I mentioned previously there is a
mechanism for biasing right in essence
you tune the the language model you turn
the the weight of the of the language
model to kind of like condition it to
keywords but that is not enough
so how we do How We Do It
we offer our
of the book
of the of the self-ready models to be
fine-tuned
specifically we attach at the end size
of the model adapters and we perform
adapter efficient fine tuning
you you as a customer come and in your
tenant project that you have in your gcp
basically you have a budget with at
least 100 hours of audio data and we
perform the training for you
specifically that happens through the
console through the UI or through the
API you point the model the base model
which means the language of your choice
and the local and the GCS packet that
has all the audio data and then we
perform the training
that specifically means that you as a
customer
end up with only one model and ask
Google we don't have any access to that
your weights are your weights your IP
which is reflecting your data set is
only your IP
with training happens in our TPU V2 and
V3 and it takes about a day maybe maybe
two in accordance to how many uh all the
hours you grant the model access to
consume and last but not least this is
all available through the V2 API
now what happens as soon as you have
trained the model
with a two-step process you can
automatically Benchmark and you can
automatically deploy
benchmarking how it works basically on
another GCS packet or in the same one
you have a separate directory which you
have audio and text we suggest about
having 10 hours worth of audio with a
corresponding ground truth so we do the
benchmarking for you and then when with
the simple click into our Google Cloud
console you can deploy the model into
whichever region you want
how how that thing though translates to
the end at the end in product in
production
on the vertical axis you can see how
many hours of audio data we have um we
have provided our model into our
internal testing here and you can see
with only 100 hours of audio you can see
that we get about 15 a relative word
error Improvement if you crank that to
400 hours you can see that we're getting
gains of 30 to 35 percent relative World
error Improvement and mind you it's not
across the board it's specific to your
use case your product names and exactly
the audio conditions that we see
in your use case that is massive for our
customers again tying back to the story
that column said coming as close as we
can to our Enterprise customers
we'll be around afterwards thank you so
much and uh yeah don't forget to rate it
if you can thanks
[Music]